all right guys my producers just sat me
down and told me something very
important is happening across the
worldwide web apparently Grand Theft
Auto 6 which is Grand Theft Auto vice uh
is coming out in
2025 now uh the last Grand Theft Auto
that came out which was Grand Theft Auto
five took place in Los Angeles that was
10 years ago and it was the number one
selling video game of all time I never
played that one I did play Grand Theft
Auto Vice City which was a little bit
before that believe I played that on the
PS2 it was pretty much the end of my
video game career because I didn't know
what the hell was going on I would just
punch hookers and steal cars so it was
kind of similar to my regular life uh
but in any event uh the trailer for the
new one has come out uh for vice and
apparently it takes place in Miami and
the GU said you got to watch this thing
and we got to record you while you're
watching it so here we
go
luia do you know why you're here bad
luck I
[Music]
guess there was a
girl she said she cared about
me she tried to make my
world it's like it's like my dayto day
so
far yeah we were
desperate and the graphics to have each
other like driving to
[Music]
[Applause]
work well look who's
back the only way we're going to get
through
this is by sticking together
being a
team which part of Miami is
this
trust
[Music]
[Applause]
trust I don't know it looks pretty
good